- So the question is what would
actually happen to your body
if you really gave up sugar,
I mean completely, for two weeks?
Let's take a look at that.
Number one, you are gonna
lose your appetite to sugar.
Why?
Because every time you consume sugar,
a hormone comes in there and
pushes your blood sugars down,
causing a low blood sugar situation,
hypoglycemia, to some degree
and that is gonna cause
you to crave sugar.
So by getting rid of sugar,
you get rid of the craving for sugar.
Number two, you're gonna be less hungry.
Until you do this, you
won't really fully know,
but I'm telling you,
it's the sugar that keeps
you hungry all the time.
When you give up the sugar,
you become a lot less hungry.
Why?
Because you stabilize your blood sugars
and now your cells can be actually fed
because when you're living on sugar,
because sugar is toxic to the body,
the body starts rejecting it.
That's called insulin resistance.
So the body is blocking insulin
because that controls sugar
and what your body is really trying to do
is limit the amount of
sugar inside the cells.
So the body doesn't
consider it a good thing.
It's a bad thing.
So when you give it up,
this thing could reverse.
And not only can you now
absorb proper amounts of fuel.
You'll absorb nutrients a lot better too
because insulin resistance also
blocks nutrients, minerals,
vitamins, and that's one of
the functions of insulin.
All right, number three.
You can have less fatigue
especially after eating a meal.
When you're eating sugar
on a regular basis,
usually you're gonna
be tired after you eat
and that is a blood sugar thing.
But you're gonna find
that you're no longer gonna
be that tired after you eat.
It just means that now you're
no longer having higher sugar,
which basically makes the brain tired.
It's normal sugar, and now
your brain can be awake.
All right, number four,
you're gonna lose excessive water and fat.
For the first week you're
gonna dump a lot of water
and some fat but after that,
it's gonna be more and more fat.
You're gonna be surprised how
much fluid you were retaining.
Some people within one week can lose
about 13 pounds of fluid.
They're holding that fluid around
and that can't be that
healthy for the heart.
Of course, you're gonna
see your clothes loosening,
especially on the midsection.
Your gut, your waste is
one of the best indicators
to tell if you're doing too much sugar.
If you reduce the sugar,
the stomach shrinks.
If you eat the sugar, your
stomach will expand, okay?
Number five, enhanced mood.
So if you were grouchy before,
you're now gonna be a lot
calmer, less stressed,
and you're gonna be actually
nice to be around, okay?
That's good.
Also your cognitive function will improve.
So you're gonna feel more focused.
You can have more concentration.
You'll be less ADD,
more attention to focus on your projects.
Okay, number six, your skin
is gonna look much better.
You're gonna have less acne.
Your skin's gonna glow.
And that's just a
reflection of what happens.
When you consume sugar,
your insulin goes up
and also the hormone androgens,
and we're talking about females,
androgen will go up and
that's gonna create acne.
In a male body,
the increased insulin
will lower testosterone.
So you're gonna have other problems
that are associated with low testosterone.
All right, number seven,
you have less stiffness.
So you're gonna have less inflammation.
You're gonna have less pain.
So what's happening is all
we're doing is we're converting
your fuel from sugar to fat.
It takes three days, okay,
of cutting down the
carbohydrates and the sugar.
You may have a worsening of
the symptoms for three days.
Okay?
Guys, anyone can actually
handle three days.
And if you took some B
vitamins from nutritional yeast
and some potassium, you probably
won't have any symptoms.
So it's gonna be relatively easy.
At the cellular level,
you're building new enzymes
to run your body off fat fuel.
Okay, that's what's happening here.
You have a little machines
that are literally
changing over to a different fuel source.
That's what's happening
over these two weeks.
You're getting decrease
inflammation in your arteries, okay?
That's what's happening
when you get off sugar.
Less inflammation.
It's gonna help you in the long run,
prevent a clot or plaquing
and help reduce the risk of
a stroke and a heart attack.
Also you'll start growing brain cells.
Why?
Because when you reduce sugar,
then you run your body
in a different source
of fuel, called ketones,
and ketones support the
growth of nerve cells.
All right, next one, the liver.
You're gonna start dumping
some of this fat that's been
accumulating in your liver
and you're gonna use that as fuel.
So you're on your way to
cleaning out the liver
so it's no longer fatty.
By the way, as a side note,
if you have a large belly,
chances are you have a fatty liver, okay?
So by doing this, you will
reduce the fat inside your liver.
And lastly, you're gonna
have better kidney function.
Take a look at a diabetic.
The kidney is the target for problems.
When you actually cut
down the amount of sugar,
reduce the carb, you gonna
improve kidney function greatly.
All right guys, there you have it.
You may want to try this.
The proof's in the pudding.
Maybe I should talk about pudding,
but this is the icing on the cake.
Now maybe I shouldn't
even talk about that.
All right, thanks for watching.
Hey guys, I'm not sure if you
have my app yet, Dr. Berg App.
It's totally free.
You should download it.
Okay, this is what it looks like.
You click it.
It gives you all sorts of great resources.
I have all my YouTube videos on this app.
And it's regularly uploading
the most recent ones.
All the YouTube videos are also
converted to audio versions.
Okay, so you can use
it when you're walking,
exercising, driving your car.
I have a mini course on there.
I'll be putting additional courses.
I have a lot of recipes on there
and this is new, and also PDF resources.
So there's various downloads,
PDFs that you can get as well.
And if you wouldn't mind
after you download it,
check it out,
give me your unbiased review
and tell me how you like it.
I want to know.